gentiment officiellement la campagne
n'est pas commencé mais regardez ce
ministre libéral de la région
on se rend bien compte que le défilé
électorale est bien en marche c'est la
prérogative du premier ministre de
déclencher les élections mais je pense
que les gens sentent déjà un 20 81
vendent élections qui s'en vient le
gouvernement qui double métier le
suspense mais en coulisses les rumeurs
veulent que la campagne pourrait être
déclenchée dès jeudi cette semaine peu
importe le scénario les autres partis
n'attendent pas pour démarrer la machine
si les premières chef visiter rien donc
on a beaucoup d'aidé nourriture végétale
le npd a beau être le premier à dévoiler
son véhicule de campagne le parti est à
la traîne dans la nomination des
candidats
à quelques jours du déclenchement ils en
ont toujours 133 l'échelle du pays
jobs médecine veut une équipe
représentative de la population
ça prend plus de temps mais j'ai j'ai
voulu le faire parce que c'est important
pour moi de changer les statuts cours
pour encourager plus des fins plus et
qui monte mineurs est apte
le chef du bloc québécois aussi étaient
à pied d'oeuvre au rassemblement à
rimouski pour investir un nouveau
candidat
il déplore que justin trudeau tarde à
donner le coup d'envoi
une tactique selon lui pour nuire aux
formations comme la sienne à la plus
tard l'élection est déclenché - les
remboursements sont importants pour des
partis qui ont moins de moyens que les
riches libéraux pour les conservateurs
la stratégie libérale est clair procédé
ou plus grand nombre possible d'annoncés
gouvernementales avant le début de la
campagne
justin trudeau a devrait continuer à
dépenser d'énormes sommes d'argent pour
acheter son élection il va forcer les
canadiens paient le prix après des
élections
c'est comme une carte de crédit la
campagne doit être lancé au plus tard
d'ici une semaine
le choix de la date revient au premier
ministre et justin trudeau a bien
l'intention de tirer profit de l'effet
de surprise
il appartiendra à ses adversaires
d'adapter leurs horaires en fonction de
son choix
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa